hey everyone davolo here and in today's
video we're kind of what I think to be
one of the most underrated fires from
throughout jiujitsu Kaizen like I don't
know why but when this fight first
dropped people going around talking
about a smack here and there calling the
culling games boring and underwhelming
which makes absolutely no sense
especially like when you look at what is
currently going on in the story like oh
my Lord they foreshadowed me for future
events that are now unfolding in this
story that it tastes throughout this
brutal Showdown are amazing and I think
everyone who first thought otherwise
needs to quickly head into the
re-evaluation chamber this fight here
follows our slash kill wannabe Mega me
and is extremely important first battle
throughout the Tokyo colony from inside
of kinjaku's world altering culling game
plus this is also the last time we see
fushiguro for a good while inside of the
culling game so just sit back and enjoy
yourselves as we go of these top tier
hands so tiny bit of like relative
information on how a boy ended up in the
situation just before we do get into the
video well after both Yuji and Megami
into the colony together they find
themselves independently moved to one of
nine different spawn locations after a
few scuffles and just the usual Giga
info down with his new characters and
techniques the duo managed to meet up
with some new people who know where
their first Target is inside of the
Tokyo Colony yet sadly Mega me is
completely and utterly doped by this
cute ass chick and it should have been
led to hagarumer he was actually brought
into a trap with registar an old school
sorcerer from a few hundred years back
was line and wait but yeah anyway
hopefully that brings you all up to date
on how the current events have unfolded
anyway enough of that let's get into
this video immediately Reggie is like oh
oh well I guess this tour has broken
down causing a random fodder player to
shoot out behind Mega me and try to
attack him with a set of claw hands so
obviously this dude is another of the
guys I like to call it body modification
curse users with Yuji we had the cap
dude and of course the rocket here girl
now we've got claw man right here Mega
me manages to slip into the slow Shadow
Vanessa's Divine dog attacks Reggie he
reappears from below the fodder claw man
picking him up and simply throwing his
ass off the side of the building it's
per usual though making me always double
Taps his opponents and commands in a way
to dive from home shockingly player and
slammingham into the ground below
probably murking him back in the
building two kitchen knives are suddenly
shoved into the Divine dog's mouth and
capacitating the shikagami as Mega me
turns back Reggie says that he knows
what he's up to and wants his adversary
he'll die if he doesn't fight for real
on cue a random eye suddenly appears
over the side of the building next to
Mega me and abruptly detonates causing
an explosion which almost takes out even
Reggie above them we find a player named
iori hazanoki one of Richie's allies and
another of those body modification users
the now one-eyed sorcerer begins
breaking off some more of his teeth
while asking if their target is dead
however Megami is saying quickly darting
out of his smoke and immediately
avoiding a follow-up attack sent by Remy
he manages to grabu here and slams her
onto the ground aggressively he asks her
if she's had enough but before she can
answer hazanoki jumps down from the
floor above and tosses his teeth at Mega
me at the same time Reggie also sends
through a few receipts that transform
into gas and splash all over Mega me
soaking him then into some crazy ass
combination with the gasoline hazanoki
detonates his teeth resulting in a mess
of blast that erupts through the top of
the building seemingly taking out both
Remy and mega me exit in a room Reggie
asks if he finished but hazanoki says he
saw Megami duck into another room to
avoid taking damage inside of that said
room Mickey moves a door that he used to
protect himself in Remy and asks her if
she understands now as the explosions
could have easily killed her as well
proving that she's completely and
utterly disposable me tries to leave her
behind but Remy attempts to stab him
again with her here then instantly
switching up she desperately begs Mega
me to say that he likes her and then he
will protect her disgusted making me
realizes that Remy is the type of trash
who only cares about words rather than
someone's actions chizuru so like
remember that random dude making me
disposal right at the start of the
scuffle well it turns out he didn't
actually die and stupidly demand decides
to reach when they battle he compliments
Mega me for getting the better of him
before but notes that this student must
be in rough shape now he mentions it was
a pain scaling the building and hearing
this Mega me is like yo what are you
what are you dumb dude why didn't you
take the stairs suddenly both of the
vehicle games appear and announce that a
new rule has been added to the culling
game so this is obviously the point in
the arc that Yuji and Higa rumors battle
ends with them finally adding that new
role surprise and reinvigorated making
me Smiles instantly he restarts the
fight kicking he fought a full back and
summoning his prolific Max elephant
which materializes inside the building
completely destroying the upper floors
as it comes thundering down sticking
with lightning itself Mega me then uses
Norway to catch himself allowing him to
mount chizuru in mid-air after getting
on top and still falling Megami slashes
his face over and over with the health
of a sword before jumping off and
kicking him into the ground below having
crashed heavily into the ground Chooser
to curses Megami yet before he can even
get up Mega me who ain't no damn Yuji
simply slashes his face open with his
sword and eliminates him free moment
make me questions what he's doing
because I need more points in the future
they quickly refocus by reminding
himself that sakumi won't have to
participate in the Kelly now escogan
rewards him with five points migami
reaffirms to himself that he just needs
to deal with the difficulties as they
come descending down to ground level
with your opponences Reggie has left
surprise and even embarrassed by
chizuru's lack of skill back with our
boy he notices that he's still at number
two to one and is now feeling the
effects of the first explosion thinking
on what to do for a moment hit the doses
that he can't flee or use his domain
expansion because the environment still
isn't compatible with his technique
before he can think up of anything to do
hazunoki abruptly spits out another one
of his bomb teeth but completely and
utterly out of nowhere someone literally
no one saw coming showed up until big
blast face first like an actual champion
to protect him as all of them stand
there utterly confused the newcomer
named fumihiko takaba who was the
failing comedian that I introduced right
at the end of the previous Jujutsu
kaising video or it might even be the
one before that one now well he and one
of the might Superhero level voices
states that two-on-one fights are unfair
and calls Richie and his minion complete
cowards he adds that their attacks have
done zero damage however it's shown that
the attack completely busted open his
face and hid making it clear that it was
in fact hurt confusing Mega me looking
at Mega me takaba decides to help him
because their 35 year old can tell
whether someone is good or bad just by
their face yet after looking at him
again he realizes that Mega me actually
has a bad face but writes it off is all
revisionist which is just obviously
wrong in me to say relative mechanisms
just left stunned with this new person
but regardless of his personality this
random man just saved him so the Jiu
Jitsu High student is willing to trust
him for now Regine hazunoki don't even
recognize takaba they try asking what
time period is from takaba though who
isn't even listening to them explains
that his costume is based on a funny
superhero causing his intimidation
factor to suddenly flare up while
preparing to tell another absolutely
terrible joke the enemy Duo prepare for
an attack but takaba darts into a JoJo
whisk pose and tells a joke they could
say did silent reaction the Harvest
screams that damn it's a tough crowd but
continues to hide himself up nonetheless
even though his opponents are stiff
takable will continue to do what he does
best because he's an Entertainer of the
highest degree he screams flying forward
and delivering an insane double-footed
flying dropkick that connects with
hazanoki's face sending him crashing
into a nearby building sent in there
Reggie notes the shift into Carver's
output of cursed energy and quickly
realizes that the failing comedian is
actually super strong tacaba stunting on
all of them does a handstand while
explaining that he's an old-school
performer who's pro-violence using the
confusion to his Advantage Megami tries
to launch a surprise attack on Reggie
from his own shadow but his foe manages
to jump away from the ground in time to
avoid it now back with his new teammates
migami tries to explain to him
hazunoki's exploding body parts but only
ends up getting annoyed telling takaba
to stop getting so close to his face
bringing out cogame they use him to
confirm that hegaruma was indeed the one
who added a new role he's surprised and
is sure to see that Yuji had completed
their mission because of this he states
that he's done with this colony and
tells Reggie he'll let him go if he
backs off Richie just straight up
annoyed now refuses because he needs to
make up for his teammates lost points
over in their absolutely ruined building
hazunuku recovers from the Dropkick that
he just suffered and calls out to zakaba
the comedian though still just
absolutely ignores him and instead
introduces himself properly to Mega me
since tacaba is most likely going to end
up killing the bomb guy making me
request that he take kazanoki's point if
possible to which he accepts on the
condition that he continues to entertain
as first and foremost he is a performer
satisfied takaba begins sparking almost
exposing himself to the young man while
hazanoki in return sends an explosive
eye directs the atom not phase to cover
simply knocks it away with a random
paper fan he manages to close the
distance on his opponent sliding in
behind him and utterly destroying his
rectum with pervy sages Infamous 1 000
years of pain seen in his enemy into a
severe belt of pain enraged and getting
utterly photoized as the Noki swings at
him immediately follows up with a
powerful kick to his dorm that sends his
opponent through another building
standing there Mega measly flabbergasted
with takaba's show of strength and
expresses that he's glad he isn't his
enemy twister Carver tells him to stay
alive while he goes off and pounds his
opponents some more over with Reggie he
stands there thinking there's a car that
is toast either way because hazunoki
will go all out after being mocked so
much whether it's objective complete
Mega me tells his adversary to worry
about himself so that he can fight him
for real instantly he summons his max
elephant leaving Reggie blowing away
that Megami has such a large shikagami
in his Arsenal Max elephant attempts to
spray regime with a torrent of water but
he somehow manages to Dart away from the
burst attempting to take him by surprise
they can be leaps on the building above
but Richie notices in time and throws a
receipt which transforms into a net and
a snares the recently created rabbits
Mega me himself though narrowly a
voicing it and jumps onto a chain-linked
fence to break his fall as Mega me jumps
back into the road rigid activates his
innate curse technique Han contractual
Recreation and transform several
receipts into kitchen knives those in
knives fly forward towards mikami as
projectiles but is able to deflict them
with a blade of his own some rabbits are
pierced by these knives allowing Reggie
to some eyes that unlike the other
shikigami they can reappear regardless
of how many are destroyed which he
figures that Megami has likely figured
out how his curse technique Works due to
this he uses a receipt to recreate the
contract and endows himself with a
relaxing two-night stay at a five-star
Japanese earn in contrast Mega Millions
worn down from the constant fighting on
top of having used several sugar garmi
lowering his overall capacity bridges
surmises that Miami can't reconjour his
shikagami after the injured and without
the flexibility the Divine dog provides
him he's Limited in his options the old
school ads that both of them lack big
finishing moves and will need to pick
away at each other over time to achieve
Victory to which Mega me is like yeah
bro in that case I'm absolutely
so I'm a run for now out of nowhere
Norway then swoops down gravy migami
however Reggie quickly summons trash
taste boys drones equipped with the lost
luggage cameras to follow his opponents
through the sky while he watches on a
phone then summoning him moped Reggie
begins to pursue his adversary through
the streets and tracks migami's position
to a gymnasium Reggie questions whether
he really tried escaping or if he's in
fact trying to lure the fight inside of
the gym Mickey is glad to see that the
area is spacious looking up though he
suddenly sees Reggie appear on the
balcony who asks what his opponents is
plotting making me replies that big
Reggie is likely planning something as
well and the letter claimed that it's
hard to tell because Sorcerers are
nothing but con artists which is
completely and utterly true and I love
the whole idea of Reggie's thoughts on
Sorceress here it's all about like
conning your enemy into believing you've
played your final move but actually
you've just later trap and con him into
a false sense of security anyways with
the main part of this absolutely insane
battle begin suddenly two trucks appear
out of nowhere and come crashing through
the walls of the building acting quickly
making me is just able to slip under the
vehicles yet as you watches them crash
into the other wall two potted plants
are recreated above Megami they're
dropped down onto his head cracking his
skull open Richie follows up by
repeatedly slicing migami's back and
left arm with a small knife Megami tries
to retreat but gets distracted by the
unorthodox projectile Richie had just
created he's taken off guard when his
silly old carrot begins to break apart
and reveals a hidden kitchen knife
inside shooting forth the Knight stabs
directly into migami's elbow while
Richie then follows up with a brutal
front kick to his face having been
knocked down making me slides across the
gym floor thoroughly overpowered it's
explained that other things Reggie
recreates behave like shikigami
obviously knives and other things like
that can't normally fly through the air
but Reggie is able to get them to do so
with a single command big freaking Mega
me though a man made of a much darker
material response by stating that
barrier techniques are difficult for him
and he's simply unable to make an
artificial environment over a real one
however nigami doesn't need to
physically create a barrier no instead
he can use the entire gymnasium as a
perfect space for his domain as planned
Mega me casts has got a damn domain
expansion the insane kamira Shadow
Garden and forcibly encloses the barrier
around the gym to trap Reggie inside
ceiling has faked Richie who really
didn't think migami was a sorcerer
capable of using domain expansion as
utterly taken by surprise immediately
though he activates his special
anti-domain technique called Hollow
wicker basket which if you see my video
going over like all of the jjk barrier
types you know that this is the original
form of the current simple domain Reggie
believes he successfully protected
himself from their domain until four
toads appear from the liquid below his
feet and wrap up both his legs with
their tongues confused where he doesn't
understand how he's been hit after using
Hollow wicker basket and to explain that
technically Reggie's technique does
nullify this seed guaranteed hit from a
domain but because Bick old megami's
domain isn't complete and doesn't
actually have a can't miss attack it
only serves as an extension to his
cursed energy and 10 Shadows technique
that soul and Perfection has taken
Reggie off guard and mega me notices his
expression change before bridgey can
finish berating Mega me for getting
cocky he's ambushed by two Shadow clones
Richie is unable to avoid the barrage of
hairs due to the Toad's times preventing
his movements after getting pummeled
over and over which he falls back to the
ground and summons combat knives to
sever the Toad's tongues free to move
again he summons a machete and prepares
the cow to attack however megami's climb
prevents Reggie from Gaining Animo means
him by coming up from below to grab his
League then the Clone throws Reggie
towards migumi's main body who's also
armed with his sword and already
bringing it down on Reggie somehow
though regia is able to block this
attack like his reflexes are literally
insane here but now the only reverse
cards been played by our boy and it's a
three-on-one with the other Shadow clone
appearing and elbowing him directly in
the dome heavily damaged now regi just
narrowly defends a slash from Mega me
and commends the Sorcerer for his
increased function of the curse
technique considering it worse than a
lethal domain regime is aware that if
Mega me uses Max elephant and showers
him with water he'll lose this fight
refusing to allow that to happen he
activates his coustic neck and releases
a multitude of receipts into the air
above his head migumi tries to destroy
the receipts using no way but it's just
not quick enough to stop ridge's
contractual Recreation from activating
three cars are suddenly generated from
the receipts was shot straight into the
shadowy floor Reggie understands that
the entire domain is migami Shadow but
notice that Megami has only kept one
curse tool onto the length of this
entire fires he theorizes that this is
because migami has to Bear the weight of
anything kept within his shadow and now
Reggie is using the cast to turn the
domain's conditions back on mikami heavy
mean forced to the ground under the
immense weight Richard believes Mickey
might be able to summon shikigami still
so he keeps his guard up and plans to
keep on piling weight until his opponent
is completely crushed Megami though like
we all learned this throughout the first
battle against that silly old cursed
womb he literally is insane and the dude
does not care about life anymore to the
point that he tells Reggie he's
forgotten something important important
he reminds him that an incomplete domain
is still a domain and there is Shadow
All Around the both of them migami who
doesn't care suddenly conscious Max
elephant from these Shadows above Richie
causing the massive shikigami to drop
down directly on top of him having
turned their fire into a 10
weightlifting competition nikkimi
remains confident as he asks Richie
which of the two of them will be crushed
first let's explain that the average
human being can withstand about five to
six units of G-Force before losing
Consciousness making me weigh 60
kilograms and is currently carrying 2.4
tons of weight which equates to 40 units
of G-Force a fully matured elephant
weighs three to six tons and megami's
domain increases the Precision of his
curse technique replicating Max
elephant's weight realistically with
that intense weight falling atop him
Reggie fractures his right fibula and
heel bone due to the pressure alone
hidden lament over not saving the trucks
he used earlier for more weight at this
moment he's being soaked with water by
Max elephant but there are still
receipts he can remain including the
special Ace that he has up his sleeve
Reggie wonders if he can enter the
shadow below him to release his Ace and
finish off Megami he dismisses this idea
though because anything caught in the
shadow after it's dispelled might be
unable to escape furthermore he's unsure
of what it's actually like inside of
this sticky shadowy substance he decides
this option is too risky and tries to
withstand the elephant's weight while
releasing his Ace attack which he
attempts to hold up the elephant with
one arm while taking out another receipt
but before he can fully activate his
contractual Recreation Reggie succumbs
to Max elephant's immense weight and
falls into the shadow below him without
any buoyancy or resistance inside of his
shadow Reggie Falls and begins to lose
Consciousness due to the lack of oxygen
laying there above his likely defeated
opponent making me wait until he's sure
that Reggie is dead before dispelling
the domain and emptying his shadow
suddenly and coming back like a damn
King riding one of his cars when he
flies back exploding through to the surf
first rescue from certain demise now he
convenes me give me strength and emits
he's a strong sorcerer before
immediately stating that he's even
stronger though he activates another
contractual Recreation and summons a
small two-story freaking wooden house
that weighs at least 30 tons to crush
mikami in the next second Megami makes
an extremely drastic move despite using
his Ace Richie somehow abruptly finds
himself underwater again and being
strangled from behind as explained now
Mega me is using his extreme weight to
drown Richie but because of just the
immense Force that's being placed on him
he has to deactivate the curse technique
and unregister the weight of the objects
before he does actually end up dying
himself coming to Regis able to swim
back to the surface and realizes that
he's inside of a pool on the basement
level of the gymnasium making me fled
back into his shadow and entered the
domain making it so that the house broke
the floor and forced Reggie into the
pool below it's unclear how Mickey me
was able to move despite the immense
weight but Ricky theorizes that he did
so by ejecting himself from the shadow
kind of like a seesaw making me straws
up on his opponent and tells Reggie has
received a two week to use now normally
splashing their seats with water isn't
enough to make the print fade so that
alone isn't enough to stop Reggie from
reducing things however soaking the
receipts prevents Reggie from fulfilling
the condition that requires burning of
the receipts but she also notes that
making me can't summon shikigami anymore
to watch the sorcerer agrees stating
they're from now on this is a straight
up physical fight to the death Reggie
though doesn't actually believe this he
expects megaming to summon a sugigami
and plans on countering Mega me as soon
as he lets up dartinan Reggie's initial
base attack gets palmed off but as he
planned he uses that momentum to sing
meghami's sword arm bouncing back having
no defense left Reggie lifts loose with
a multitude of kicks smashing the young
sorcerer over and over again Megami
admits that Reggie is a tough opponent
made evident by his ability to withstand
Max elephant he's also a talented
martial artist with some really dope ass
techniques but he just isn't fast enough
just before Reggie is able to land a
direct hit on Megami a portion of the
far left side of Reggie's face his ear
and much of his left shoulder are
completely sheared off by someone he
thought that he'd dealt with already
having suffered a lethal blow at
blinding speed Reggie looks back to see
no one other than the Divine dog
totality which is just pissed at him
while the dog even has two scars in its
nose from the knives it's explained that
Megami was waiting until Reggie had
completely dismissed the dog and hearing
this Reggie repeats that a sorcerer is
indeed nothing but a con artist as he
collapses to the ground and a pool of
his own blood Reggie lays bleeding out
on the ground looking up at Mega me and
realizes that the domain and the Paul
concealed that Mega me could still
strike with his Divine dog Mega me
didn't flee into the gym using no way
instead had Lloyd Reggie inside standing
above him making me inquires as to what
ridges relationship to master tinken is
it's shown that there really isn't much
of a relationship he only knows him as
the hermit who is Immortal and isn't
surprised to find out he's still alive
at this time defeated with dignity
Reggie tells his co-gang to transfer all
41 of his points to Mega me with your
boy is a little annoyed about but Reggie
tells him to just consider it a good
deed before death he ads that he's just
a spectator and isn't close to kinjaku
at all with his final words said Richie
tells his executioner to let fate toy
with him before he also dies like a fool
moments later mikimi received five
points for the death of Reggie star damn
is actually such a firefight like I love
how much foreshadowing for future events
are papered throughout the story here
like is that how Megami is gonna end up
dying having sukuna who is fate in this
context I guess toy with him before he
kills him like a fool and again those
who are like past chapter 200 now also
know big Richie was correct when it came
to this just being the beginning of
something even larger so it officially
brings us to the very end of this Mega
me versus Reggie fight obviously as
Reggie has passed away here so many so
many foreshadow wins throughout this
fight but before we do move any further
and talk about them for a second before
the end of the video I just want to
thank you all again for a hundred
thousand Subs the plaque has finally
turned up which is absolutely amazing
and you know I can't thank you all
enough for it like I've said plenty of
times in the last few videos but this is
a huge goal of mine so you know look
we're just gonna keep pushing forward
and strive to get that you know like
million subscriber plate now as the
momentum and the enthusiasm I've gotten
after like receiving this has been
absolutely amazing and I'm enjoying
making videos than I have I think ever
in the past beforehand I don't know why
exactly but I'm just absolutely loving
what I'm doing right now and I hope to
be able to bring you know like more
great videos from a bunch of different
series to my channel throughout the
future but again this fight with mega me
and Richie there are so many
foreshadowings that happen throughout it
with stuff currently being explained in
the story that we've seen over chapter
200 and now of kinshaku over in the US
literally inside of the freaking White
House and then again with migami being
told that he may also die like a fool
which is extremely interesting so I
wonder if he's going to get his plans or
his goals achieved and Mega me may end
up dying like a fool I'd love to know
what you guys think down in the comment
section below so make sure you do drop a
comment down there and if you guys are
new around here and want to watch more
stuff just like this for a multitude of
different series then make sure you hit
that subscribe button and also be sure
to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with pushing my content
to a bunch of new amazing people but
anyway enough of that for now it's been
a professional degenerate diavolo and I
will see you all and above bye